hello everyone and welcome back to round
six of the feed hs dot com grand swiss
currently being played in regal latvia
it's daniel lubo versus even charged two
very strong players who are also
incredible attackers so the game is
bound to be exciting right from the
start as you'll see and
it's uh well it's it's it's a very
enjoyable game today is the rest day so
we're not going to be having round seven
but we have uh some extra time to check
up on some games from round six and this
is one such game i think the the
absolute best one from uh from the
previous round but of course i haven't
checked all of them there are far too
many so if you guys have seen uh some
that deserves to be shown uh do of
course use hashtag hashtag suggestion so
that being said uh let's check it out do
with the white pieces opens with e4 now
we have c5 going for the sicilian
defenses even usually does we have
knight to f3 d6 and now bishop to b5
check going for the canal attack knight
to d7 and now uh do both castles we have
a6 challenging the bishop and now bishop
back to d3 uh if you guys are wondering
why such a weird square for the bishop
well it's because
e2 is a bit too passive and uh c4 is a
bit too active for example if the bishop
is retreated to c4 uh then we can play
knight f6 attack the pawn now the pawn
uh is hanging uh if the bishop was on d3
the pawn would not be hanging and once
we defended b5 is very annoying now you
can't play b bishop b3 because of c4 and
then you will have to put the bishop
back so that's why the bishop is placed
on d3 right away so the pawn is defended
and you are ready to play c2 and tuck
the bishop back into uh you can play c3
and tuck the bishop back to c2 so here
knight gf6 and now c3 our pawn is nicely
defended so we can play c3 b5 and now
pawn to a4 attacking this b5 pawn we
have bishop to b7 and now a captures on
b5 a captures on b5 and now the white
rook is hanging so we have to do
something about this rook captures on a8
queen captures and we have this position
where white's e4 pawn is hanging it's
being attacked three times but also
black's b5 pawn is hanging so here we
have knight to a3 you could you could
capture on b5 it's of course uh playable
but uh duboff plays knight to a3 and i
think even knew that dubo would go for
this line uh because dubois already had
it this year in the
air things masters against maksim
vashilagrav and maksim was able to win
this game against the duval so this is
uh probably i would say what uh even was
uh going for uh so here uh we don't have
bishop captures an e4 like maxine played
against the
dubo in that tournament but instead we
have b4 and uh well what do you play
here uh well knights to b5 going for
that knight to c7 check which would win
the black queen so queen to a5 guarding
the c7 square and now there is a game
where queen to e2 was played but here we
have c captures uh c captures on b4 and
it is now only as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game uh so let's
see uh how how do we prepare this we
have c captures on b4 and now bishop to
c4 now the bishop retreats to its
rightful square and now you are ready to
start pushing those pawns uh yes you are
giving up the e4 pawn but it's something
that's really not a problem the black
king is still in the center of the board
so you will get some
counter-attacking chances so knight
captures on e4 d3 attacking the knight
now of course if the knight goes back we
can just play rook to e1 and put some
pressure on the black king so even plays
d5 and this is the absolute best way to
counter duboff's idea uh as this is a
very strong attacker dubo is trying to
give you some material for the attack so
it makes sense to neutralize the threats
so bishop to f4 now again going for that
knight the c 7 check and now of course
e5 uh we have to give something back
knight captures on e5 and now
now this is the
moment where the magic really happens so
the question is what do you play here
well you could play a lot of things but
here we have d captures on c4 just
grabbing that bishop and the problem now
is you can't really recapture here if
you capture the knight then queen
captures on d7 is just checkmate so
that's not an option you have to
be down material at least a little bit
but how can you continue this well the
the absolute main idea
uh of the you know the sort of the
source of the position is queen to h5
but it's such a complicated move that
it's really not a a wonder it wasn't
played so the idea is now of course
queen captures an f7 check king 28 queen
captures on d7 checkmate and there are
two ways you can prevent this one is to
play g6 which is not all that impressive
because after g6 we can simply play
knight captures on c4 and attack black's
queen and after queen to a4 we further
attack her with b3 and now we probably
have a trait of queens captures captures
and now the white will have this very
strong pass pawn uh for example if
knight eat the c5 uh we're going to play
rook to e1 check and after knight to e6
blocking we're gonna play this knight
seat the d6 with check and now you can't
really uh do all that much the bishop is
saying if you play king to d8 the f7
pawn hangs with check then the rook
falls so
we would probably see something like
captures captures with check and after
king e7 knight captures on b7 and we
have this position where it should be
fairly equal but white has this
dangerous past pawn maybe it could you
know
be something uh so what you would have
to do after queen to h5 is not the g6
but just the straightforward queen
captures on b5 allow queen captures here
now the queen is defending the knight
here so it's um another problem you're
not getting checkmated and after the
king moves now we see something like the
captures on e4 knight captures on e5
bishop captures we see queen captures an
e5 queen captures on b7 and we get this
position where black is up a piece but
the white has excellent chances uh of
course if black defends well
nothing is really happening for example
king e8 and now after rook to a1 we play
bishop to e7 now we're ready for this
rook to check we can block with the
bishop
and it's not really
an issue black will be able to defend
this so this is the absolute main way to
do this and it's super super complicated
but as you can see if black defends well
it doesn't really yield all that much so
here
we have d captures in c4 so a temporary
piece sacrifice uh asking black what do
you do here well it makes sense to
remove as many attackers from the board
as possible also checkmate is still
being threatened so we eliminate the
knight on e5 bishop captures on e5 and
now bishop to c5 so here if black
castles that's just it you know
no problems for black anymore
but maybe this was rushed a little bit
f6 here
would allow uh black to maybe
consolidate it a little bit better
because also the f7 square is now
available to the black king and even if
something like knight to c7 check we
play king e7 and after the bishop moves
now we play queen to c5 and everything
is nicely defended uh we can move the
king we can play bishop to d6 trade off
everything and we're gonna have a
winning game
uh so uh maybe f6 is to be considered
but okay bishop the c5 but this allows
do both to just keep the black king in
the center of the board pretty much
forever so bishop to d6 now the black
king is not castling
we have bishop captures knight captures
with czech knight captures and queen
captures now again preventing
uh and now uh bishop the c8 this is the
only move rook the e1 check is coming so
uh of course the the bishop must come to
c8 to prevent this so bishop the c8 rook
to e1 check now bishop to e6 blocking uh
sorry bishop to a6 blocking and now how
do you continue this well uh again you
have to be very very precise if you go
for the immediate c5 here which makes
sense uh it's a bit too early just queen
to d8 and now you don't really have all
that much queen to c6 check if king is
seven we're going to play queen to d
uh queen to b7 with checking out with
queen to d7 we can pick up the pawn uh
but now black just gets his work into
the game and that's it you don't really
have anything if you deliver this check
hoping for something just queen blocks
and the black is better here so duval
has to play this with absolute surgical
precision he plays rook to d1 now again
the queen can't move otherwise queen to
d8 will be checkmate so queen to a8
charge has to go all the way around he
has to play queen to ca then queen to d7
to try and fend off the attack and only
now c5 by dubo now the pawn is advancing
queen to c8 and now c6 not allowing
queen to d7
so it seems that this rook is not gonna
see the light of day anytime soon unless
you play h5 and that's exactly what even
does now the rook can be uh i put into
the game via the h6 square then maybe
you can shift it to g6 maybe even f6 all
depending on what white plays so here
rook back to e1 now uh the bishop uh i
can no longer move uh and now uh queen
to d8 if you play this now it's possible
but then queen captures on b4 then you
get another pass pawn and could be very
scary so instead even just continues
with his plan rook to h6 now comes rook
to e5 and this is a
really fine de bovian move uh you're
just you know putting that rook on on a
very nice square and asking what do you
do here of course there are some threats
of rook to b5 followed by rook to d8
which is just game over so you have to
be very very quick about it and the
question is uh how do you continue the
real question is can you afford this b3
move if you if you can then it's great
for you if you play b3 the bishop now
nicely defends the pawn and you can uh
prevented this pawn from uh reaching the
its destination then it's uh you know
it's going to be great for you for
example if you play rook to b5 here now
then uh queen to d8 is a problem and now
if uh rook to b8 we can simply play
bishop to c8 to completely uh block this
and black is just winning here now so
there is time for b3 after b3 you you'd
have to figure out how to how to go
about this so uh instead of this even
just play the queen to d8 and now dubo
of course very happily accepts this pawn
queen captures on b4 and now you don't
have to worry about any back rank issues
because the queen and rook are guarding
the e1 square
so queen to c7 now you have to
create some sort of a blockade here
against the past pawns and now queen to
c5 now dubo is preparing of course pawn
to b4 then b5 b6 and if this spawn
reaches b6 then of course it's game over
so queen the e7 offering a queen trade
and do both declines queen c3 we have
queen back to c7 and now what does dubo
do uh well of course he pushes b4 as one
always should
uh and now
uh
there's still time i mean the spawn
still hasn't done anything all that
impressive and
how do you make progress here well the
problem is if you unpin with something
like king to f8
then you really give why the tempo queen
to c5 check and after king j just b5
you're already guarding the square so
there's no uh
real way of defending this you're going
to play something like bishop the c8 but
still just rook to e8 with check and
after king to h7 you're gonna make some
breeding room for your king
for the moment the b6 is impossible
because now the c6 spawn would hang but
you have all the time in the world
you're going to play whatever for
example black plays h4 he doesn't want
this pawn to be a target here uh rook to
f8 and
black really doesn't have a
a move to play it's such an ugly
position if he tries some trickery with
some like rook to f6 we can simply play
queen h5 check and after the rook goes
back we can play queen captures on f7
and if the uh this gets traded off the
board uh rook h5 yes black is up a piece
but we're just going to play rook f8
attack the bishop and there's no point
in trying to save the bishop because
after that just c7 c8 so we're going to
play some like rook captures on b5 now
rook captures on c8 and white is of
course winning it's a rook and pawn end
game white is up two pawns so instead
after b4 even plays king to e7 it's a
stronger and the more a resilient way to
go because now after something like
queen c5 check you can block with queen
to d6 you don't have to push the king
away so instead we have b5 right away
and now rook to h8 now even uh wants to
bring the rook into the game and try and
do some damage here so here we have
queen to g3 a very interesting move by
double uh you could of course play many
different ideas but this is just the
sharpest one you're kind of attacking
the g7 pawn but also your real threat is
just rook captures on e6 king captures
and queen captures and c7 this comes
with check so of course it's completely
winning uh so dooba sets a trap and even
sets a counter trap he plays rook to d8
now he says all right if you play this
now
then we know how this ends captures with
check capture so i lose the queen but
you get checkmated so that's uh what
ivan is hoping for uh not really he of
course knows
he's not going to fall for this but it's
a it's a very nice active defense uh so
here dubo just plays h4 he creates some
breeding room for his king so he doesn't
have to worry about back rank issues uh
and now
is the uh
well now it's just the right moment for
for even to finally uh you know
utilize what he's been working for and
i'm going to show you a line that allows
black to do just such thing so for
example rook to d1 check king to h2 and
now queen to d6 preparing to bring the
rook to d5 to trade off everything from
the board uh yes you have to give up one
pawn but it doesn't really matter rook
to d5 and now for example if f4 we
simply trade rook captures on e5 queen
captures an e5 queen captures f captures
and king to d8 uh yes black is up a
piece but it's uh five points against
two this will be a very easy draw for
example b6 king to c8 and then now after
g3 we're gonna play bishop to d5 uh
we're gonna play c7 after king to b7
king to f4 we give up this pawn and now
king g5 and now the
the
light square bishop will have to
keep guarding those pawns unless
you want to lose this game with black it
being up a piece so this is the way
black should continue but it's um
of course not an easy easy decision to
make
and also black is very low on time so
here even played king to f8 it's really
the thing that he's been working for the
entire game he wanted to get this rook
from hh to d8 and now he was successful
in doing so the king is no longer on the
e file so even the bishop can move and
you know good things could happen for
black now the only problem is the
position is now completely lost for even
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for do both while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
well uh we we have to say uh brilliancy
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course rook
captures on e6 it doesn't matter that it
doesn't come with check it's still
completely winning and this is what the
duo played and there's uh even um a
recording of this great moment on camera
so i'm going to play it for you uh
olympic and posted it on twitter uh so
let's just check it out there you can
see double plays rook captures on e6 and
you can see uh such powerful energy it
completely blew even away from the board
we can even check it out one more time
and uh
olympia even said that the duo's games
are uh such fire that they have they
keep him playing next to a fire
extinguisher so there you have it one
more time just calmly grabbing that and
even knows that now it's all over
uh so yeah rook captures an e6 was
played and the queen is still hanging so
you have to capture the queen so queen
captures was played f captures on g3 and
now f captures on e6 so even is now up a
full rook uh but it doesn't matter just
c7 by duboff yeah and now if you try and
block this just b6 king to a7 and b7 and
that's it rook captures we bring a queen
into the game it's all over so even has
to give the rook back he plays king to
a7 but it doesn't help c captures on the
e8 and it doesn't matter you can bring
any piece into the game you want the
position is still winning for white
because this is basically a king and
pawn end game uh so double brought the
queen into the game he's not feeling you
know like goofing around uh king
captures on the e8 and now king to f2
and now we have this king and pawn end
game where dubo is up upon and it's an
outsidish pass pawn uh this pawn that
would never be here if you haven't
pushed it to b4 you know at that correct
moment so king to c7 king to e3 king to
b6 now we have king to d4 king captures
on b5 and king to e5 and he was in this
position on mu 42 that even sharich
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the position is
completely winning and uh well we we can
just show it real quickly if you go here
we're just going to capture upon if you
go you know for those pawns down the
board it doesn't really matter kanye
three king captures here king f2 we're
gonna go king to h6 you're gonna capture
here we're gonna capture here captures
here and now this pawn is just winning
uh so yeah after king to e5 even
resigned and another great victory for
for daniel dubov and a tough loss for
even charge because he also lost uh in
the previous round to alexei shirov uh
after a really really uh impressive and
hard-fought game uh but uh very nice for
duba and i would also like to mention
that sometimes you know when you're
going through these games there are like
108 players are playing the at this
tournament and you go through the final
positions and you see this position and
you're like no i'm not going to even
watch this game it's some sort of a you
know silly game that go to win straight
for the end game when in fact it's you
know
pure fire on the board uh yeah as they
have double playing next to a fire
extinguisher
uh but yeah yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh if you guys are
interested in the standings after these
six rounds so we have a five people thai
uh furuja is still in first place with
the four and a half out of six followed
by maxine bashar al-agrav um afghani
nair krishna
and uh alexei shiro so all five of them
on four and a half followed by a bunch
of people of course with four out of six
so we'll we'll see what happens in round
seven but today is a rest day so we're
going to check out some games from round
six uh before tomorrow's game start
uh so yeah uh once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i i really had an
incredible time just preparing this for
you because there were so many lines and
so many lines that i haven't shown you
because it would last forever but i hope
that the ones i have you guys enjoyed uh
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank lucas theocary james
mayberry abdul el traore
frank holmes and david little for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
incredible event until it ends
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day